You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.|||你之前说这个地方离水边就几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路在哪。我们省了多少钱？够了。够来一场说走就走的旅行！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅数步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Are you dreading the cold months ahead? With fewer hours of daylight, bare trees, and slush, snow, and freezing rain in the forecast,
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. Are you dreading the cold months ahead? With fewer hours of daylight, bare trees, and slush, snow, and freezing rain in the forecast,|||希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得你期望的入住体验。当你想要的是省钱，而不是惊吓。住哪里很关键。希尔顿，伴你每一次入住。你是否在恐惧即将到来的寒冷月份？随着白昼时间变短、树木光秃秃，以及天气预报中出现的融雪、积雪和冻雨，
winter often seems like a season to be endured rather than celebrated. But in Scandinavia, where the winters are among the coldest and darkest on Earth, many people look forward to winter as a time of coziness, beauty, and rest. So what can we learn from the way that Scandinavians approach the season? How can our mindset, the way we think about winter, change how we experience it? How do cold weather and darkness affect our body and mind? And how might we work with the changing seasons rather than against them to appreciate what winter has to offer? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
winter often seems like a season to be endured rather than celebrated. But in Scandinavia, where the winters are among the coldest and darkest on Earth, many people look forward to winter as a time of coziness, beauty, and rest. So what can we learn from the way that Scandinavians approach the season? How can our mindset, the way we think about winter, change how we experience it? How do cold weather and darkness affect our body and mind? And how might we work with the changing seasons rather than against them to appreciate what winter has to offer? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.|||冬天似乎往往是一个只能忍受而非庆祝的季节。但在斯堪的纳维亚半岛，这里的冬天是地球上最寒冷、最黑暗的地区之一，许多人却将冬天期盼为舒适、美丽和休息的时光。那么，我们可以从斯堪的纳维亚人对待这个季节的方式中学到什么？我们的心态，即我们对冬天的看法，又该如何改变我们对它的体验？寒冷的天气和黑暗如何影响我们的身心？我们又该如何顺应而非对抗季节的变化，去欣赏冬天所馈赠的一切？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Carrie Lee. Ljibowitz, a health psychologist, speaker, and writer who studies the power of mindsets to improve our health and well-being. In 2014, she spent a year in Tromsome, Norway, above the Arctic Circle, to study how people experience winter there. In her new book, How to Winter, Harness Your Mindset to Thrive on Cold, Dark, or Difficult Days, she discusses how psychological science and lessons from Norway and other cold-weather countries
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Carrie Lee. Ljibowitz, a health psychologist, speaker, and writer who studies the power of mindsets to improve our health and well-being. In 2014, she spent a year in Tromsome, Norway, above the Arctic Circle, to study how people experience winter there. In her new book, How to Winter, Harness Your Mindset to Thrive on Cold, Dark, or Difficult Days, she discusses how psychological science and lessons from Norway and other cold-weather countries|||我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是凯莉·李·利博维茨（Carrie Lee. Ljibowitz）博士，她是一位健康心理学家、演讲者和作家，主要研究心态改善我们健康和福祉的力量。2014年，她在北极圈以北的挪威特罗姆瑟度过了一年，研究人们在那里的冬季体验。在她的新书《如何过冬：利用你的心态在寒冷、黑暗或艰难的日子里蓬勃发展》（How to Winter, Harness Your Mindset to Thrive on Cold, Dark, or Difficult Days）中，她探讨了心理学科学以及来自挪威和其他寒冷国家的经验教训，
can help us find more contentment and happiness in the season. Dr. Liebuwitz, thank you for joining me today. So happy to be here. Thanks for having me. I'd like to start by asking about Tromso. Much of your research on winter mindset springs from the year you spent there back in 2014. Can you tell us what's winter like in Tromso? What's the weather like? How much daylight to the yet?
can help us find more contentment and happiness in the season. Dr. Liebuwitz, thank you for joining me today. So happy to be here. Thanks for having me. I'd like to start by asking about Tromso. Much of your research on winter mindset springs from the year you spent there back in 2014. Can you tell us what's winter like in Tromso? What's the weather like? How much daylight to the yet?|||如何帮助我们在这一季节找到更多的满足感和快乐。利博维茨博士，非常感谢您今天能作客节目。很高兴来到这里。谢谢您的邀请。我想先问一下关于特罗姆瑟的问题。你关于冬季心态的很多研究，都源于2014你在那里度过的那一年。你能告诉我们特罗姆瑟的冬天是什么样的吗？天气怎么样？还有多少白昼时间？
And how do people feel about winter there? So Tromsa is a really unique place. It's over 200 miles north of the Arctic Circle. It's a small island of about 70,000 inhabitants. And because it's so far north, they have really extreme changes in daylight between the seasons. So in the summer, they have two months of what's called the midnight sun where the sun never sets. And in the winter, they have the opposite. So what's called the polar night.
And how do people feel about winter there? So Tromsa is a really unique place. It's over 200 miles north of the Arctic Circle. It's a small island of about 70,000 inhabitants. And because it's so far north, they have really extreme changes in daylight between the seasons. So in the summer, they have two months of what's called the midnight sun where the sun never sets. And in the winter, they have the opposite. So what's called the polar night.|||那里的居民对冬天有什么感受？特罗姆瑟是一个非常独特的地方。它位于北极圈以北200多英里处。这是一个约有7万居民的小岛。由于它地处极北，不同季节的白昼时间变化极为极端。所以在夏天，他们有长达两个月的所谓“午夜太阳”，太阳永不落山。而在冬天，情况则完全相反，也就是所谓的“极夜”。
So in Tromsa, the sun sets on November 21st and doesn't rise again for two months until. January 21st. Now, when a lot of people hear this, they think full darkness, full night time. That does happen farther north, but Tromsa has what's called civil twilight. So that's the time when the sun is just below the horizon. So, you know, the way the sky gets light before the sun officially rises or stays light after it sets, you get that for anywhere from sort of two to five or six hours a day during the polar night. And that light can be very beautiful. It's very soft. It's not direct. You can have, if it's a clear day, these amazing sunrise and sunset colors. It also makes the world very blue. A lot of people like to refer to the polar night as the blue time. It's the time of
So in Tromsa, the sun sets on November 21st and doesn't rise again for two months until. January 21st. Now, when a lot of people hear this, they think full darkness, full night time. That does happen farther north, but Tromsa has what's called civil twilight. So that's the time when the sun is just below the horizon. So, you know, the way the sky gets light before the sun officially rises or stays light after it sets, you get that for anywhere from sort of two to five or six hours a day during the polar night. And that light can be very beautiful. It's very soft. It's not direct. You can have, if it's a clear day, these amazing sunrise and sunset colors. It also makes the world very blue. A lot of people like to refer to the polar night as the blue time. It's the time of|||所以在特罗姆瑟，太阳在11月21日落下，接下来的两个月里都不会升起，直到1月21日。现在，许多人听到这个消息时，会认为是漆黑一片、漫长的黑夜。更偏北的地方确实如此，但特罗姆瑟拥有所谓的“民用曙暮光”。也就是太阳刚好在地平线以下的这段时间。你知道的，就是太阳正式升起之前天空变亮，或者日落之后天空依然有光的那种状态，在极夜期间，你每天大约能享受到两到五或六个小时的这种光线。这种光线可以非常美丽。它非常柔和，不是直射的。如果是晴天，你还能看到令人惊叹的日出和日落色彩。它也让整个世界呈现出蓝调。许多人喜欢把极夜称为“蓝色时光”。那是
year where the world is very blue tinted. And Tromsa also has a unique climate because it's located on the Gulf stream. So even though it's so far north, it's actually a lot warmer than you might expect. So the average winter temperatures are usually in the 20s Fahrenheit, which is cold below freezing. It's very snowy. But considering that it's 200 miles north of the Arctic Circle, it's not as cold as most people expect. And if you go inland away from the coast, it gets much, much colder relatively quickly. So it has these really interesting winter conditions where it's definitely snowy, definitely cold, definitely wintry, but also the darkness is a big thing, that the polar night is really one of the things that makes Trumso the most extreme in terms of climate. And people there have varying opinions about the winter. Of course, there are people like everywhere who struggle with that time of year, who struggle with a lack of vitamin D or they have a hard time getting up in the morning.
year where the world is very blue tinted. And Tromsa also has a unique climate because it's located on the Gulf stream. So even though it's so far north, it's actually a lot warmer than you might expect. So the average winter temperatures are usually in the 20s Fahrenheit, which is cold below freezing. It's very snowy. But considering that it's 200 miles north of the Arctic Circle, it's not as cold as most people expect. And if you go inland away from the coast, it gets much, much colder relatively quickly. So it has these really interesting winter conditions where it's definitely snowy, definitely cold, definitely wintry, but also the darkness is a big thing, that the polar night is really one of the things that makes Trumso the most extreme in terms of climate. And people there have varying opinions about the winter. Of course, there are people like everywhere who struggle with that time of year, who struggle with a lack of vitamin D or they have a hard time getting up in the morning.|||一年中世界带有浓重蓝色调的时期。特罗姆瑟还有一个独特的气候，因为它位于墨西哥湾暖流上。所以尽管它地处极北，但实际上比你想象的要温暖得多。因此，冬季平均气温通常在华氏20多度（约零下几度），也就是冰点以下的寒冷。雪下得很大.但考虑到它位于北极圈以北200英里处，它并没有大多数人想象的那么冷。如果你向内陆走，远离海岸，相对而言气温会迅速变得非常非常冷。所以它有这些非常有趣的冬季条件，这里绝对下雪、绝对寒冷、绝对有冬天的氛围，但黑暗也是一个大问题，极夜确实是让特罗姆瑟在气候上显得最为极端的因素之一。那里的人们对冬天有着不同的看法。当然，就像任何地方一样，有些人很难熬过那段时间，他们面临维生素D缺乏的问题，或者早上很难起床。
But there's a lot of people who really appreciate the polar night and who find it to be extremely magical, extremely peaceful, cozy, and really see it as a very special and beautiful time of year. And that was something that, you know, before I moved there, I was imagining this sort of darkness, foreboding, scary. And I was surprised by how gentle and gorgeous it was without the sun. Now, you say in your book that you were not a big fan of winter before you move there. So were you worried about how you would handle the cold and all that darkness? I was. I mean, other researchers out there may be familiar with this experience. You know, you apply for a bunch of research grants. Most of them you don't get.
But there's a lot of people who really appreciate the polar night and who find it to be extremely magical, extremely peaceful, cozy, and really see it as a very special and beautiful time of year. And that was something that, you know, before I moved there, I was imagining this sort of darkness, foreboding, scary. And I was surprised by how gentle and gorgeous it was without the sun. Now, you say in your book that you were not a big fan of winter before you move there. So were you worried about how you would handle the cold and all that darkness? I was. I mean, other researchers out there may be familiar with this experience. You know, you apply for a bunch of research grants. Most of them you don't get.|||但也有许多人非常欣赏极夜，他们发现极夜极其神奇、极其宁静、舒适，并真正将之视为一年中非常特殊和美丽的时光。而在我搬到那里之前，我一直在想象这种黑暗是不祥的、可怕的。但没有太阳的那些日子竟然如此温柔和绚丽，这让我感到惊讶。你在书中提到，在搬到那里之前，你并不是冬天的粉丝。那么，你是否担心自己如何应对寒冷和所有的黑暗？我是担心的。我的意思是，其他研究人员可能对这种经历并不陌生。你知道的，你申请了一堆研究经费。其中大部分你都拿不到。
And so you're not really intending to actually follow through with all of them. And so I had put out a bunch of sort of fellow. ship applications to go abroad. And then I got this one to go move to the Arctic for a year. And I was like, oh my God, what if I done? Like, am I really going to move to this place? You know, I grew up on the Jersey shore south of New York City in a town where summer was king and we sort of lived for the summers and the beach time. And I did not enjoy the winter. I really didn't and still don't really enjoy the feeling of being cold. I really struggled with winter mornings growing up, especially in high school. And I was really unsure what it would be like to live through such an extreme winter.
And so you're not really intending to actually follow through with all of them. And so I had put out a bunch of sort of fellow. ship applications to go abroad. And then I got this one to go move to the Arctic for a year. And I was like, oh my God, what if I done? Like, am I really going to move to this place? You know, I grew up on the Jersey shore south of New York City in a town where summer was king and we sort of lived for the summers and the beach time. And I did not enjoy the winter. I really didn't and still don't really enjoy the feeling of being cold. I really struggled with winter mornings growing up, especially in high school. And I was really unsure what it would be like to live through such an extreme winter.|||所以你其实并没有打算把所有的申请都付诸实践。因此我投递了许多出国访问学者的申请。然后我拿到了这个去北极生活一年的名额，当时我就想，天哪，我都干了些什么？难道我真的要搬到这个地方去吗？你知道的，我在纽约市以南的泽西海岸长大，那里的夏天是王道，我们的生活可以说是为了夏天和海滩时光而存在的。我并不喜欢冬天。我真的不喜欢，现在也依然不太喜欢寒冷的感觉。在成长过程中，我真的很讨厌冬天的早晨，尤其是在高中时。对于经历这样一个极端的冬天会是什么样子，我心里完全没底。
And the people I talked to when I told them I was moving to this city in the Arctic, especially in the US, people had really strong reactions. People would say things like, I could never do that. I would be so depressed. Like, don't you think you're going to get depressed? And so both my own internal narrative and also the cultural narrative around me was that this was going to be an extremely challenging and a harsh environment on something I was really going to have to try my best just to endure and make it through. But it didn't turn out that way. No, that wasn't really the story I encountered in Norway. I mean, you know, and I think this really speaks to the value of doing cultural research and spending time on the ground in these places, right? Because, you know,
And the people I talked to when I told them I was moving to this city in the Arctic, especially in the US, people had really strong reactions. People would say things like, I could never do that. I would be so depressed. Like, don't you think you're going to get depressed? And so both my own internal narrative and also the cultural narrative around me was that this was going to be an extremely challenging and a harsh environment on something I was really going to have to try my best just to endure and make it through. But it didn't turn out that way. No, that wasn't really the story I encountered in Norway. I mean, you know, and I think this really speaks to the value of doing cultural research and spending time on the ground in these places, right? Because, you know,|||当我告诉别人我要搬到北极的这座城市时，我交谈过的人——尤其是在美国——都有着非常强烈的反应。人们会说这样的话：“我绝对做不到。我会抑郁死的。”“难道你不觉得你会得抑郁症吗？”因此，无论是我内心的自白，还是我周围的文化叙事，都认为这将是一个极其具有挑战性和严酷的环境，我必须竭尽全力才能忍受并熬过去。但事情并非如此。不，这并不是我在挪威真正遇到的情况。我的意思是，你知道的，我认为这真正说明了进行文化研究并在这些地方实地考察的价值，对吧？因为，你知道的，
in the end, the research study I did there was a survey and now you can do online surveys from anywhere. But so much of my research was informed by living in this place and talking to the people there and talking to people about what winter was going to be like, what I should be looking at, what I should be thinking about. And I was just finding that people in Tronso how to really do different relationship to the winter than I had growing up in New Jersey. Despite the winter being longer, darker, darker, colder, harsher in many respects, people there talked about the things they were looking forward to. They looked forward to skiing and coziness and the beauty of the polar night and the film festival that happens in the dark time in January and all of these things
in the end, the research study I did there was a survey and now you can do online surveys from anywhere. But so much of my research was informed by living in this place and talking to the people there and talking to people about what winter was going to be like, what I should be looking at, what I should be thinking about. And I was just finding that people in Tronso how to really do different relationship to the winter than I had growing up in New Jersey. Despite the winter being longer, darker, darker, colder, harsher in many respects, people there talked about the things they were looking forward to. They looked forward to skiing and coziness and the beauty of the polar night and the film festival that happens in the dark time in January and all of these things|||最终，我在那里做的研究是一项调查，现在你可以在任何地方进行在线调查。但我的很多研究都是通过在这个地方生活、与当地人交谈、与人们讨论冬天会是什么样子、我应该关注什么、我应该思考什么而获得启发。我发现特罗姆瑟的人们与冬天的关系，和我从小在新泽西长大的经历真的很不一样。尽管那里的冬天在许多方面更漫长、更黑暗、更寒冷、更严酷，但当地人却在谈论他们所期待的事情。他们期待滑雪、舒适感、极夜的美丽、一月黑暗时期举办的电影节，以及所有这些
that they weren't focused on all of the things to come that would be annoying or uncomfortable or unpleasant. They were really oriented towards the opportunities of the season and the things that made the season special that they were looking forward to. Now, the subtitle of your book is harness your mindset to thrive on cold, dark, or difficult days. And before we talk about a winter mindset, could you define more broadly, What is a mindset? Why is it important? Sure. So I completed my PhD in psychology at Stanford University working in the Stanford Minded Body Lab with Professor Alia Crum. And, you know, this follows the tradition of Dr. Carol Dweck
that they weren't focused on all of the things to come that would be annoying or uncomfortable or unpleasant. They were really oriented towards the opportunities of the season and the things that made the season special that they were looking forward to. Now, the subtitle of your book is harness your mindset to thrive on cold, dark, or difficult days. And before we talk about a winter mindset, could you define more broadly, What is a mindset? Why is it important? Sure. So I completed my PhD in psychology at Stanford University working in the Stanford Minded Body Lab with Professor Alia Crum. And, you know, this follows the tradition of Dr. Carol Dweck|||他们并没有把注意力集中在即将到来的那些烦人、不舒服或令人不快的事情上。他们真正关注的是这个季节带来的机遇，以及让这个季节变得特别、令他们期待的事物。你的书的副标题是“利用你的心态在寒冷、黑暗或艰难的日子里蓬勃发展”。在我们谈论冬季心态之前，你能更广泛地定义一下：什么是心态？为什么它很重要？当然。我在斯坦福大学完成了心理学博士学位，在斯坦福身心实验室（Stanford Minded Body Lab）与阿利亚·克拉姆（Alia Crum）教授一起工作。你知道的，这延续了卡罗尔·德韦克（Carol Dweck）博士的传统，
and her work on growth in fixed mindsets about intelligence. And so the definition I use really comes from Dr. Alia Crum and the Stanford Minded Body Lab, which is that we think of mindsets as a core assumption or belief about something in the world and how it works. So they tend to be very basic and very broad, right? Intelligence is fixed or intelligence is malleable. Stress is enhancing for performance and well-being or debilitating for performance and well-being. Winter is wonderful or winter is dreadful. Winter is full of opportunity or winter is limiting. And a lot of the time we have these mindsets and they might be influencing us, but we're not always aware of these sort of really broad assumptions that we have
and her work on growth in fixed mindsets about intelligence. And so the definition I use really comes from Dr. Alia Crum and the Stanford Minded Body Lab, which is that we think of mindsets as a core assumption or belief about something in the world and how it works. So they tend to be very basic and very broad, right? Intelligence is fixed or intelligence is malleable. Stress is enhancing for performance and well-being or debilitating for performance and well-being. Winter is wonderful or winter is dreadful. Winter is full of opportunity or winter is limiting. And a lot of the time we have these mindsets and they might be influencing us, but we're not always aware of these sort of really broad assumptions that we have|||以及她关于智力的成长型和固定型心态的研究。因此，我使用的定义实际上来自阿利亚·克拉姆博士和斯坦福身心实验室，即我们认为心态是关于世间某事及其运作方式的核心假设或信念。所以它们往往非常基本且非常广泛，对吧？智力是固定的，或者是可塑的。压力会提升表现和福祉，还是会损害表现和福祉。冬天是美好的，或者是可怕的。冬天充满机遇，或者是充满限制的。很多时候，我们拥有这些心态，它们可能在影响着我们，但我们并不总是意识到我们对世界上这些非常基本的事物所持有的这种非常广泛的假设。
about these very basic things in the world. If a person wants to change their attitude toward winter, then how do they change their winter mindset? Where do you start? I think you start by recognizing that you have a winter mindset, right? You know, we all go through winter and we have ideas about winter. We have these mindsets. We have schemas. We have expectations. We have all these associations that come up with the season. And recognizing that those in and of themselves are
about these very basic things in the world. If a person wants to change their attitude toward winter, then how do their change their winter mindset? Where do you start? I think you start by recognizing that you have a winter mindset, right? You know, we all go through winter and we have ideas about winter. We have these mindsets. We have schemas. We have expectations. We have all these associations that come up with the season. And recognizing that those in and of themselves are|||如果一个人想要改变对冬天的态度，那么他们该如何改变自己的冬季心态呢？你从哪里开始？我认为要从认识到自己拥有某种冬季心态开始，对吧？你知道的，我们都经历过冬天，对冬天都有自己的看法。我们有这些心态、有图式、有期望、有所有与这个季节相关的联想。并且要认识到这些本身就是
powerful and that those are influencing our experience. So taking stock of your mindset, noticing it, trying to think about what comes up for you when you think about winter, when you envision going into the season is really important. And then I think there's lots of different strategies that we can do for changing our mindset. So we can do things like deliberately focus our attention, right? So mindsets are, they're biased. You know, the truth is that winter, like lots of things, is complex. There's parts of winter that are dreadful and annoying and uncomfortable. And there are parts that are special and beautiful and wonderful. That's true of any season. That's true of almost anything that we encounter in the world. But what we,
powerful and that those are influencing our experience. So taking stock of your mindset, noticing it, trying to think about what comes up for you when you think about winter, when you envision going into the season is really important. And then I think there's lots of different strategies that we can do for changing our mindset. So we can do things like deliberately focus our attention, right? So mindsets are, they're biased. You know, the truth is that winter, like lots of things, is complex. There's parts of winter that are dreadful and annoying and uncomfortable. And there are parts that are special and beautiful and wonderful. That's true of any season. That's true of almost anything that we encounter in the world. But what we,|||强有力的，它们正在影响着我们的体验。因此，盘点你的心态、注意到它、试着去思考当你想到冬天时会浮现出什么、当你设想进入这个季节时会有什么感受，这些都非常重要。然后我认为我们可以采取许多不同的策略来改变我们的心态。比如我们可以做一些事情，例如刻意集中我们的注意力，对吧？所以心态是有偏见的。你知道的，事实是，冬天和许多事情一样是复杂的。冬天的某些部分是糟糕、烦人且令人不舒服的。也有一些部分是特殊、美丽而奇妙的。任何季节都是如此。我们在世界上遇到的几乎任何事情也都是如此。但我们，
attend to more influences what we feel about the winter, influences our motivation and how we behave with the winter. And so we can start consciously nudging our attention towards noticing the things that we do like, right? So if you wake up and it's a cold, wet, rainy day, are you going to immediately jump into noticing and thinking about how this is going to make your commute more difficult or how you don't want to go outside and walk your dog in this weather? or are you going to jump into how this is the perfect weather for putting on your favorite sweater, for getting a mug of something hot,
attend to more influences what we feel about the winter, influences our motivation and how we behave with the winter. And so we can start consciously nudging our attention towards noticing the things that we do like, right? So if you wake up and it's a cold, wet, rainy day, are you going to immediately jump into noticing and thinking about how this is going to make your commute more difficult or how you don't want to go outside and walk your dog in this weather? or are you going to jump into how this is the perfect weather for putting on your favorite sweater, for getting a mug of something hot,|||更多地关注什么，就会影响我们对冬天的感受，影响我们的动力以及我们面对冬天的行为方式。因此，我们可以开始有意识地引导我们的注意力，去注意那些我们真正喜欢的事物，对吧？所以如果你醒来发现这是一个寒冷、潮湿、下雨的日子，你是会立刻开始注意到并思考这会如何让你的通勤变得更加困难，或者你多么不想在这种天气里出门遛狗？还是你会转而想到，这是穿上你最喜欢的毛衣、泡一杯热饮的完美天气，
for doing work inside in front of a computer or reading a book or whatever it is, and your experience of that day and that weather is going to be really different depending on what you attend to. We can also leverage other strategies in our behaviors like we can cultivate winter rituals to give ourselves things to look forward to in the season. We can leverage social support,
for doing work inside in front of a computer or reading a book or whatever it is, and your experience of that day and that weather is going to be really different depending on what you attend to. We can also leverage other strategies in our behaviors like we can cultivate winter rituals to give ourselves things to look forward to in the season. We can leverage social support,|||是在电脑前进行室内工作、读一本书或做其他事情的绝佳时刻？根据你关注的焦点不同，你对那一天和那种天气的体验将会有所不同。我们还可以在行为中利用其他策略，比如我们可以培养冬季仪式感，让我们在这个季节里有值得期待的事情。我们可以利用社会支持，
so we can lean on our friends and family for cozy indoor activities, but also to help us get outside in the winter when maybe it doesn't come as easily. So a lot of these broad motivational strategies that we use in psychology to help us do anything we want to do to achieve our goals can help us change our mindset about winter and see the season a bit differently. In the book, you advise people to get outside during the winter, even though you may think that it's cold and it's going to be unpleasant. Why is getting outside so important?
so we can lean on our friends and family for cozy indoor activities, but also to help us get outside in the winter when maybe it doesn't come as easily. So a lot of these broad motivational strategies that we use in psychology to help us do anything we want to do to achieve our goals can help us change our mindset about winter and see the season a bit differently. In the book, you advise people to get outside during the winter, even though you may think that it's cold and it's going to be unpleasant. Why is getting outside so important?|||所以我们可以依靠朋友和家人来进行舒适的室内活动，同时也可以在冬天可能没那么容易出门时，借助他们的帮助走到户外。因此，我们在心理学中用来帮助自己实现任何目标的许多广泛的动机策略，都可以帮助我们改变对冬天的心态，以不同的视角看待这个季节。在书中，你建议人们在冬天走到户外，尽管你可能会觉得外面很冷、体验会很不愉快。为什么走到户外如此重要？
This is something I really observed all throughout Scandinavia, certainly when I lived in Tromso and also when I traveled elsewhere from my book, that being outside in the winter is really important to embracing the season. And I think there's a couple of reasons why this is. One is that we know that connection with nature, movement, and fresh air are all all natural antidepressants. So if you feel a little bit down in the winter, going outside and moving your body just a little bit even is going to be an antidote to some of those feelings and is going to really change your mood.
This is something I really observed all throughout Scandinavia, certainly when I lived in Tromso and also when I traveled elsewhere from my book, that being outside in the winter is really important to embracing the season. And I think there's a couple of reasons why this is. One is that we know that connection with nature, movement, and fresh air are all all natural antidepressants. So if you feel a little bit down in the winter, going outside and moving your body just a little bit even is going to be an antidote to some of those feelings and is going to really change your mood.|||这是我在整个斯堪的纳维亚半岛都观察到的现象，无论是在特罗姆瑟居住期间，还是为了写书去其他地方旅行时，我都发现冬天待在户外对于拥抱这个季节至关重要。我认为这有几个原因。其一是我们知道，与大自然的联系、运动和新鲜空气都是天然的抗抑郁剂。因此，如果你在冬天感到有点沮丧，走到户外稍微活动一下身体，就能成为对抗这些负面情绪的解药，并真正改变你的心情。
We know that, you know, walking even for a little bit or connecting with nature for a little bit provides a mood boost and an emotional boost. I also think that when we think about winter mindset broadly, really it boils down to whether we see the season as one of limitations or one full of opportunities. And I think when we think about winter limiting us, we so often focus on the things that we can't do or that we feel that we can't do in the winter. And a lot of those involve going outside and enjoying the outdoors. And so when we practice bundling up for the elements, wearing our layers, putting on waterproof, raincoats and boots and things, and going outside, we can begin to see that it is possible to go outside and enjoy ourselves in winter weather. And not only does this overturn some of our narratives about the limitations of the season, it also makes other things easier, right? Like when your friends invite you to go lean up somewhere, but in order to do that, you have to go outside and brave the cold.
We know that, you know, walking even for a little bit or connecting with nature for a little bit provides a mood boost and an emotional boost. I also think that when we think about winter mindset broadly, really it boils down to whether we see the season as one of limitations or one full of opportunities. And I think when we think about winter limiting us, we so often focus on the things that we can't do or that we feel that we can't do in the winter. And a lot of those involve going outside and enjoying the outdoors. And so when we practice bundling up for the elements, wearing our layers, putting on waterproof, raincoats and boots and things, and going outside, we can begin to see that it is possible to go outside and enjoy ourselves in winter weather. And not only does this overturn some of our narratives about the limitations of the season, it also makes other things easier, right? Like when your friends invite you to go lean up somewhere, but in order to do that, you have to go outside and brave the cold.|||我们知道，你知道的，即使只是散步一小会儿或与大自然接触一会儿，也能提振心情和情绪。我还认为，当我们广义地思考冬季心态时，它实际上归结为我们是将这个季节视为充满限制的季节，还是充满机遇的季节。我认为，当我们认为冬天限制了我们时，我们常常把注意力集中在那些我们不能做的事情上，或者我们觉得自己不能在冬天做的事情上。其中许多事情都涉及走到户外并享受户外活动。因此，当我们练习为了抵御恶劣天气而裹紧衣服、穿上层层衣物、穿上防水雨衣和靴子等并走到户外时，我们就会开始看到，在冬天的天气里走到户外并尽情享受是完全可能的。这不仅颠覆了我们对这一季节局限性的一些固有看法，还让其他事情变得更容易，对吧？就像当你的朋友邀请你去某处聚会时，但为了做到这一点，你必须出门去顶住严寒。
That becomes a barrier to doing things. So the more that you practice getting outside and dressing up and being in the elements, the less that becomes a barrier to doing other things that might be good for your health and well-being in the winter, whether that's going to the gym or meeting up with friends or going out to movies and museums and things that are particularly well-being. suited to indoor winter time, but you still have to go outside and leave your house to get there. And I think that that is a really powerful lesson. This is actually something that I assign my students to do in the workshops that I give and in the classes that I teach about winter mindset, is I assign them to bundle up the Scandinavians have a saying, there's no such thing as bad weather, only bad clothing, and go outside for a winter excursion. And then they have to write a reflection about it. And so often it's people being like, I didn't want to do this. I was thinking of any
That becomes a barrier to doing things. So the more that you practice getting outside and dressing up and being in the elements, the less that becomes a barrier to doing other things that might be good for your health and well-being in the winter, whether that's going to the gym or meeting up with friends or going out to movies and museums and things that are particularly well-being. suited to indoor winter time, but you still have to go outside and leave your house to get there. And I think that that is a really powerful lesson. This is actually something that I assign my students to do in the workshops that I give and in the classes that I teach about winter mindset, is I assign them to bundle up the Scandinavians have a saying, there's no such thing as bad weather, only bad clothing, and go outside for a winter excursion. And then they have to write a reflection about it. And so often it's people being like, I didn't want to do this. I was thinking of any|||这就成了做事情的障碍。因此，你越是练习出门、盛装打扮并置身于自然环境中，它成为阻碍你在冬天做其他对健康和福祉有益事情的障碍就越少，无论是去健身房、与朋友聚会，还是去看电影、参观博物馆，这些都非常适合冬天的室内时光，但你仍然必须出门并离开家才能到达那里。我认为这是一个非常深刻的教训。实际上，这也是我在举办的工作坊以及教授的关于冬季心态的课程中布置给学生的一项作业，我让他们穿好衣服——斯堪的纳维亚人有一句名言：没有坏天气，只有糟糕的衣服——然后去外面进行一次冬季远足。接着他们必须写一篇反思。通常人们都会觉得：“我不想做这个。我想找任何
excuse to bail. I go outside. I'm so uncomfortable. And then they're outside, five, 10, 15 minutes. They're moving their body. They're walking. They're noticing there's all this beauty around them. Actually, they're not as cold as they were when they first stepped outdoors. Their body's heating up. Their mood is lifting. And I can't tell you how many people who said that they didn't want to do this assignment, end up then having repeat outdoor winter excursions after being assigned to go outdoors in the winter. And so it's something you really have to try yourself to, I think, fully embody the impact that it has. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for
excuse to bail. I go outside. I'm so uncomfortable. And then they're outside, five, 10, 15 minutes. They're moving their body. They're walking. They're noticing there's all this beauty around them. Actually, they're not as cold as they were when they first stepped outdoors. Their body's heating up. Their mood is lifting. And I can't tell you how many people who said that they didn't want to do this assignment, end up then having repeat outdoor winter excursions after being assigned to go outdoors in the winter. And so it's something you really have to try yourself to, I think, fully embody the impact that it has. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for|||借口溜走。”我走到外面。我太不舒服了。然后他们在室外待了五分钟、十分钟、十五分钟。他们在活动身体。他们在散步。他们注意到周围有这么多美景。实际上，他们并没有刚迈出户外时那么冷了。他们的身体在变暖。他们的情绪在提升。我无法告诉你，有多少人曾说过他们不想做这个作业，但在被指派去冬季户外之后，最终却开始反复进行户外冬季远足。所以这是你必须亲自尝试的事情，我认为才能真正体会到它所产生的影响。你的夏天现在就开始了，家得宝（The Home Depot）推出阵亡将士纪念日优惠活动。是时候开启夏季烧烤了，Next Grills 四燃烧器燃气烤炉特价促销，
only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price-in-valid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You studied people in Tromso, and they grew up there, so this is what's normal to them. So wouldn't you think that they would have learned how to cope? I mean, did you find a lot of people who really didn't or people who didn't like winter. Did they, did they just leave that part of Norway? Yeah. So I think people there struggle with aspects of the season. I think some people
only $199 and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies, price-in-valid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You studied people in Tromso, and they grew up there, so this is what's normal to them. So wouldn't you think that they would have learned how to cope? I mean, did you find a lot of people who really didn't or people who didn't like winter. Did they, did they just leave that part of Norway? Yeah. So I think people there struggle with aspects of the season. I think some people|||仅需 199 美元，还有汉普顿湾 (Hampton Bay) West Grove 七件套户外用餐组合，整季招待亲友无忧，仅售 499 美元。在这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效时间为5月14日至5月27日，仅限美国，适用除外条款。详情请参见 Home Depot.com slash price match。你研究了特罗姆瑟的人们，他们在那儿长大，所以这对他们来说是再正常不过的事了。那你难道不认为他们已经学会了如何应对吗？我的意思是，你有没有发现很多人其实并不适应，或者有不喜欢冬天的人？他们难道……难道就没有离开挪威的那部分吗？是的。所以我认为那里的人们也在与这个季节的某些方面作斗争。我认为有些人
feel the effects on their energy, have a hard time getting up. You know, we know that light and dark influences our circadian rhythms. And certainly I also struggle waking up in the morning when it's darker in the winter. And so there are people there who do have a hard time. If you really hate I think you would move somewhere else, although, you know, even if you move to southern Norway, to Oslo, it's still pretty dark. So unless you're going to leave the country entirely, it's hard to get away from winter in Norway. And I think that that is part of it. It's like you said, you know, they grow up there. They learn how to behave in the winter.
feel the effects on their energy, have a hard time getting up. You know, we know that light and dark influences our circadian rhythms. And certainly I also struggle waking up in the morning when it's darker in the winter. And so there are people there who do have a hard time. If you really hate I think you would move somewhere else, although, you know, even if you move to southern Norway, to Oslo, it's still pretty dark. So unless you're going to leave the country entirely, it's hard to get away from winter in Norway. And I think that that is part of it. It's like you said, you know, they grow up there. They learn how to behave in the winter.|||会感受到它对精力的影响，早上很难起床。你知道的，我们知道明暗会影响我们的生物钟。当然，冬天变黑的时候，我在早上醒来时也很挣扎。所以那里确实有些人觉得很难熬。如果你真的很讨厌，我想你会搬到别的地方去，尽管，你知道的，即使你搬到挪威南部的奥斯陆，天黑得还是挺早的。所以除非你完全离开这个国家，否则在挪威很难摆脱冬天。我认为这也是其中一部分。就像你说的，你知道的，他们在那里长大。他们学会了在冬天如何表现。
And they almost have no choice but to adapt. I think it's actually when you live somewhere where the winter is more extreme, where the darkness is more extreme, it's obvious that you have to change your behavior to adapt to winter. It's obvious that maybe you would slow down and sleep more and rest more in the dark season and be more active and doing even more things outside in the midnight sun in the summer. It's obvious that you have to change your wardrobe and how you dress. It's obvious that you have to change the way you light your house. And so they develop these behaviors that I think are,
And they almost have no choice but to adapt. I think it's actually when you live somewhere where the winter is more extreme, where the darkness is more extreme, it's obvious that you have to change your behavior to adapt to winter. It's obvious that maybe you would slow down and sleep more and rest more in the dark season and be more active and doing even more things outside in the midnight sun in the summer. It's obvious that you have to change your wardrobe and how you dress. It's obvious that you have to change the way you light your house. And so they develop these behaviors that I think are,|||并且他们几乎别无选择，只能去适应。我认为实际上当你住在冬天更极端、黑暗更极端的地方时，很显然你必须改变自己的行为来适应冬天。很显然，在黑暗的季节里，你可能会慢下来、多睡一会儿、多休息一会儿；而在夏天的午夜太阳下，你会更加活跃，在户外做更多的事情。很显然，你必须改变你的衣柜和着装方式。很显然，你必须改变给房屋照明的方式。所以他们养成了这些行为，我认为这些行为
extremely helpful in embracing the season in working with the season because they're doing things differently in the winter. I think those of us who live at more middle latitudes don't have that same urgent need to change our behavior. We sort of delude ourselves into thinking, oh yeah, I can have the same schedule year round. I can be equally productive year round. I can basically dress the same and I'll just throw on a coat in the winter year-round, you know? And I think that really does us a disservice because I think one of the real ways of celebrating winter is leaning into what the season offers and doing things a little bit differently at that time of year than you do in, you know, the spring or the summer or the fall. And that's where I think these lessons from these more extreme climates can really help us.
extremely helpful in embracing the season in working with the season because they're doing things differently in the winter. I think those of us who live at more middle latitudes don't have that same urgent need to change our behavior. We sort of delude ourselves into thinking, oh yeah, I can have the same schedule year round. I can be equally productive year round. I can basically dress the same and I'll just throw on a coat in the winter year-round, you know? And I think that really does us a disservice because I think one of the real ways of celebrating winter is leaning into what the season offers and doing things a little bit differently at that time of year than you do in, you know, the spring or the summer or the fall. And that's where I think these lessons from these more extreme climates can really help us.|||对于拥抱这个季节、顺应这个季节极其有帮助，因为他们在冬天做事情的方式有所不同。我认为我们这些生活在中纬度地区的人没有那么迫切需要改变行为的需求。我们有点自欺欺人地认为：“哦，是的，我全年都可以保持相同的日程安排。我全年都可以保持同样的效率。我基本上可以穿一样的衣服，冬天套上一件大衣就行了，你知道吗？”我认为这真的对我们没有好处，因为我认为庆祝冬天的真正方式之一就是顺应这个季节所提供的东西，并在一年中的那个时候做一些与你在春天、夏天或秋天时略有不同的事情。这就是我认为这些更极端气候带来的经验真正能够帮助我们的地方。
It seems like it might be easier to love winter when you live somewhere like Tromso, with the northern lights and sparkling snow and the things that you're talking about that they do to make their lives pleasant. But what if you live somewhere where it's just gray and chilly and drizzly? I mean, here in the D.C. area, for example, we get more freezing rain than snow, which is really not fun. How can people approach that kind of winter with a positive mindset? Yeah, I think this is a really important question. I do think in some ways, trumso is the idealized version of winter, you know, like if you watch Disney's Frozen, like, that's kind of the land you're living in. There's a lot of beauty and there's a lot of like winter wonder.
It seems like it might be easier to love winter when you live somewhere like Tromso, with the northern lights and sparkling snow and the things that you're talking about that they do to make their lives pleasant. But what if you live somewhere where it's just gray and chilly and drizzly? I mean, here in the D.C. area, for example, we get more freezing rain than snow, which is really not fun. How can people approach that kind of winter with a positive mindset? Yeah, I think this is a really important question. I do think in some ways, trumso is the idealized version of winter, you know, like if you watch Disney's Frozen, like, that's kind of the land you're living in. There's a lot of beauty and there's a lot of like winter wonder.|||当你住在像特罗姆瑟这样有极光、闪闪发光的雪以及你所说的那种能让生活变得愉悦的事情的地方时，爱上冬天似乎更容易一些。但如果你住在那种只有灰色、阴冷和毛毛雨的地方呢？我的意思是，比如在华盛顿特区地区，我们的冻雨比雪多，这真的非常没意思。人们怎么能以积极的心态面对那样的冬天呢？是的，我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。我的确认为在某些方面，特罗姆瑟是理想中的冬天版本，你知道的，就像如果你看过迪士尼的《冰雪奇缘》，就像，那就是你生活的那种土地。有很多美景，也有很多像冬日奇观一样的东西。
But I think that a lot of these lessons from tromso can apply in these other climates. And I know that, you know, like you said, in the D.C. area, in other middle latitude places like in London or New York. work, you know, you have a lot of people living with not a lot of snow and a lot of gray, chilly rain. I myself actually live in Amsterdam right now, which does not get snow almost ever anymore, but it's very gray and dark and rainy all winter. And so the question is, what are the lessons we can learn from a more idealized winter place that we can bring wherever we are? So one is, I think making the season special by working with the darkness, right? So lighting candles, embracing low lights, embracing it as a time of year to slow down and do calmer, more peaceful
But I think that a lot of these lessons from tromso can apply in these other climates. And I know that, you know, like you said, in the D.C. area, in other middle latitude places like in London or New York. work, you know, you have a lot of people living with not a lot of snow and a lot of gray, chilly rain. I myself actually live in Amsterdam right now, which does not get snow almost ever anymore, but it's very gray and dark and rainy all winter. And so the question is, what are the lessons we can learn from a more idealized winter place that we can bring wherever we are? So one is, I think making the season special by working with the darkness, right? So lighting candles, embracing low lights, embracing it as a time of year to slow down and do calmer, more peaceful|||但我认为特罗姆瑟的许多经验都可以应用到其他气候中。我知道，就像你说的，在华盛顿特区地区，在其他中纬度地区，比如伦敦或纽约。工作，你知道的，有很多人生活在没有多少雪、只有大量阴冷雨水的地方。我自己目前实际上住在阿姆斯特丹，这里几乎再也不下雪了，但整个冬天都非常灰暗、阴暗和多雨。所以问题是，我们可以从一个更理想的冬日之地学到什么经验，并把它带到我们身处的任何地方？所以其中之一，我认为是通过顺应黑暗来让这个季节变得特别，对吧？比如点燃蜡烛，拥抱微弱的灯光，将它视为一年中慢下来、做一些更平静、更安详的事情的时期。
indoor activities and really relishing in the darkness for the opportunities it provides, right? If you drive around your town or city and you enjoy looking at the Christmas lights, that's a gift of winter darkness, right? You don't get that one. it stays light out very late. The ability to eat dinner by candlelight or have an early movie night or have a cozy night indoors reading. All of those things are not just things you can do in the dark, but I would argue things that are better in the dark and that winter gives us the opportunity to really enjoy. I would also say that, you know, every climate has pros and cons, right? So if you live somewhere that is a lot colder, winters tend to be longer and darker,
indoor activities and really relishing in the darkness for the opportunities it provides, right? If you drive around your town or city and you enjoy looking at the Christmas lights, that's a gift of winter darkness, right? You don't get that one. it stays light out very late. The ability to eat dinner by candlelight or have an early movie night or have a cozy night indoors reading. All of those things are not just things you can do in the dark, but I would argue things that are better in the dark and that winter gives us the opportunity to really enjoy. I would also say that, you know, every climate has pros and cons, right? So if you live somewhere that is a lot colder, winters tend to be longer and darker,|||室内活动，并真正享受黑暗所带来的机遇，对吧？如果你开车绕着你的城镇或城市兜风，喜欢看圣诞彩灯，那是冬日黑暗的礼物，对吧？当外面天黑得很晚时，你可享受不到这个。在烛光下吃晚餐的能力，或者有一个早早的电影之夜，或者在室内度过一个舒适的阅读之夜。所有这些事情不仅是你在黑暗中可以做的事情，而且我认为这些事情在黑暗中会更好，而冬天给了我们真正享受这些事情的机会。我还想说，你知道的，每种气候都有利有弊，对吧？所以如果你住在更寒冷的地方，冬天往往更漫长、更黑暗，
but you get the benefits of snow and sort of that winter beauty. If you live somewhere that tends to be rainier and grayer and chillier, chances are that you live somewhere where actually the days are longer in the winter. And if you really start paying attention to the weather, you might notice more winter sun than you thought you had in your town. A lot of places I know that this is true in Amsterdam. I know it's very true in London, have these reputations of like, oh, it rains for six months. It rains all winter long. But if you actually pay attention, that's really not the case that, you know, a lot of these places, even the rainiest months, they might average 13 or 14 rainy days a month. And even on those days,
but you get the benefits of snow and sort of that winter beauty. If you live somewhere that tends to be rainier and grayer and chillier, chances are that you live somewhere where actually the days are longer in the winter. And if you really start paying attention to the weather, you might notice more winter sun than you thought you had in your town. A lot of places I know that this is true in Amsterdam. I know it's very true in London, have these reputations of like, oh, it rains for six months. It rains all winter long. But if you actually pay attention, that's really not the case that, you know, a lot of these places, even the rainiest months, they might average 13 or 14 rainy days a month. And even on those days,|||但你能享受到雪的好处以及那种冬日的美丽。如果你住在往往更多雨、更阴暗、更寒冷的地方，你所居住的地方在冬天的白昼可能实际上更长一些。如果你真的开始关注天气，你可能会注意到你的镇上的冬日阳光比你想象的要多。我知道很多地方在阿姆斯特丹是这样的。我知道在伦敦也确实如此，它们都有这样的名声，比如，哦，这里下六个月的雨。整个冬天都在下雨。但如果你真的去注意，事实并非如此，你知道的，许多这样的地方，即使在雨水最多的月份，他们平均每个月也可能只有13或14个雨天。甚至在那些日子里，
it's not raining the whole day, right? So can you go outside on your lunch break and feel the winter sun on your face on a clear day. Can you enjoy being outdoors on days that it's not rainy? And then I would also say, you know, winter weather can be really fascinating if we let it be, right? So I think, you know, you can lean into the rain being beautiful, the rain being something that enables you to have this cozy time indoors, the rain that is good for activities that maybe get crowded out when it's warm and sunny. So for me, in the summer, when it's, It's warm and sunny. I want to be outside. I want to be picnicking. I want to be swimming. I want to be riding my bike. But in the winter, that's my time to read my books. It's my time to be in the
it's not raining the whole day, right? So can you go outside on your lunch break and feel the winter sun on your face on a clear day. Can you enjoy being outdoors on days that it's not rainy? And then I would also say, you know, winter weather can be really fascinating if we let it be, right? So I think, you, you can lean into the rain being beautiful, the rain being something that enables you to have this cozy time indoors, the rain that is good for activities that maybe get crowded out when it's warm and sunny. So for me, in the summer, when it's, It's warm and sunny. I want to be outside. I want to be picnicking. I want to be swimming. I want to be riding my bike. But in the winter, that's my time to read my books. It's my time to be in the|||也不是下一整天雨，对吧？所以你能在午休时间走到户外，在晴天感受冬日的阳光洒在脸上吗？在不下雨的日子里，你能享受户外活动吗？然后我还想说，你知道的，如果我们允许的话，冬天的天气其实可以非常迷人，对吧？所以我认为，你可以顺应雨的美丽，雨是让你在室内享受这段舒适时光的事物，雨有利于那些在天气温暖晴朗时可能会被挤掉的活动。对我和来说，在夏天，当天气温暖晴朗时。我想待在户外。我想去野餐。我想去游泳。我想骑自行车。但在冬天，那是我读书的时间。那是我在
pottery studio. It's my time to cook more elaborate meals. It's my time to bake things. And those are things that the season really lends itself to that I look forward to doing on a rainy day. Even my work as a writer, it's really hard for me to write on a warm, sunny day. Like, I want to be out sorry. Right. Yeah. I don't want to be in front of my computer, you know. But like when I can have my cup of tea and my little desk candle, I can, you know, sort of get into the zone of writing a little bit more easily. And so some of it is sort of intentionally romanticizing and leaning into the opportunities of that chilly gray wet weather. I'm going to change this subject to seasonal effective disorder, which I think a lot of our listeners probably know about. I'm just wondering
pottery studio. It's my time to cook more elaborate meals. It's my time to bake things. And those are things that the season really lends itself to that I look forward to doing on a rainy day. Even my work as a writer, it's really hard for me to write on a warm, sunny day. Like, I want to be out sorry. Right. Yeah. I don't want to be in front of my computer, you know. But like when I can have my cup of tea and my little desk candle, I can, you know, sort of get into the zone of writing a little bit more easily. And so some of it is sort of intentionally romanticizing and leaning into the opportunities of that chilly gray wet weather. I'm going to change this subject to seasonal effective disorder, which I think a lot of our listeners probably know about. I'm just wondering|||陶艺工作室度过的时间。那是我烹饪更精致餐点的时间。那是我烘焙食物的时间。这些都是这个季节非常适合做的事情，也是我期待在下雨天做的事情。甚至作为一名作家，要在温暖晴朗的日子里写作对我也很难。就像，我想出去抱歉。对。是的。你知道的，我不想坐在电脑前。但就像当我可以喝着茶、点着小书桌蜡烛时，你知道的，我可以稍微更容易地进入写作状态。所以其中一部分是有意地将那种寒冷、阴暗、潮湿的天气浪漫化，并顺应它所带来的机遇。我要把话题转到季节性情感障碍（SAD）上，我想我们的很多听众可能对此有所了解。我只是想知道
how common is sad and how does it differ from simply feeling more tired and less energetic in the winter? Yeah, this is a really important topic because I think there's a lot of confusion around seasonal effective disorder. So seasonal effective disorder is defined in the DSM-5, the diagnostic and statistical manual for diagnosing mental disorder. as a subtype of clinical depression. So in order to be diagnosed with seasonal affective disorder, someone first has to meet the threshold for clinical depression. And then we can say, okay, is there a seasonally recurring pattern, which most often happens in the winter. You can actually have summer seasonal affective disorder, but it's much rarer.
how common is sad and how does it differ from simply feeling more tired and less energetic in the winter? Yeah, this is a really important topic because I think there's a lot of confusion around seasonal effective disorder. So seasonal effective disorder is defined in the DSM-5, the diagnostic and statistical manual for diagnosing mental disorder. as a subtype of clinical depression. So in order to be diagnosed with seasonal affective disorder, someone first has to meet the threshold for clinical depression. And then we can say, okay, is there a seasonally recurring pattern, which most often happens in the winter. You can actually have summer seasonal affective disorder, but it's much rarer.|||SAD有多普遍？它与冬天单纯感到更疲惫、精力更少有什么区别？是的，这是一个非常重要的话题，因为我认为围绕季节性情感障碍存在很多困惑。因此，季节性情感障碍在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》第五版（DSM-5）中被定义为临床抑郁症的一个亚型。因此，要被诊断为季节性情感障碍，一个人首先必须达到临床抑郁症的阈值。然后我们才能说，好吧，是否存在季节性复发的模式，这种情况最常发生在冬天。你实际上也可能会患有夏季季节性情感障碍，但要罕见得多。
But I think this cultural narrative that winter is depressing is so pervasive, coupled with the idea that a lot of people do feel more tired in the winter, maybe less motivated, maybe less social. And they have this top of mind explanation of, oh, seasonal effective disorder is lots of people are out there saying, yes, I have winter depression, I have seasonal effective disorder, who would not say, oh, yeah, I have clinical depression. When in fact, you know, in order to actually meet the criteria, first you would have to say, yes, I have clinical depression. then you can say I have seasonal effective disorder.
But I think this cultural narrative that winter is depressing is so pervasive, coupled with the idea that a lot of people do feel more tired in the winter, maybe less motivated, maybe less social. And they have this top of mind explanation of, oh, seasonal effective disorder is lots of people are out there saying, yes, I have winter depression, I have seasonal effective disorder, who would not say, oh, yeah, I have clinical depression. When in fact, you know, in order to actually meet the criteria, first you would have to say, yes, I have clinical depression. then you can say I have seasonal effective disorder.|||但我认为“冬天令人沮丧”这种文化叙事是如此普遍，再加上许多人在冬天确实感到更疲惫、动力可能更少、社交可能更少这种观念。他们脑海中首先浮现的解释是：“哦，季节性情感障碍就是……”许多人在外面说：“是的，我有冬季抑郁症，我有季节性情感障碍。”谁会不愿说“哦，是的，我有临床抑郁症”呢？而事实上，你知道的，为了真正符合标准，首先你必须说：“是的，我有临床抑郁症。”然后你才能说我有季节性情感障碍。
There's a lot of disputes about seasonal effective disorder and how quote unquote valid it is. It depends a lot on what measure you use. So when it was originally discovered, which it was discovered in the U.S., in the D.C. area in Maryland, the instrument that was used to diagnose it was called the SPAC, the seasonal pattern assessment questionnaire. And what this measure did is it measured your seasonality.
There's a lot of disputes about seasonal effective disorder and how quote unquote valid it is. It depends a lot on what measure you use. So when it was originally discovered, which it was discovered in the U.S., in the D.C. area in Maryland, the instrument that was used to diagnose it was called the SPAC, the seasonal pattern assessment questionnaire. And what this measure did is it measured your seasonality.|||关于季节性情感障碍及其所谓的“有效性”，有很多争议。这很大程度上取决于你使用什么测量方法。所以当它最初被发现时（它是在美国的马里兰州华盛顿特区地区被发现的），用于诊断它的工具被称为SPAC，即季节模式评估问卷。这种测量方法的作用是衡量你的季节性。
It measures, you know, which months do you feel the most tired, the most social, the most energetic? Do you change your eating habits? Do you change your sleeping habits? Do you change your socializing? Which months do you feel the best and worst? And the idea is that if you have really extreme seasonality, then you have winter depression. So if you say, oh, I sleep a lot more, I eat a lot more, I'm a lot less social in the winter, than you could be diagnosed with seasonal effective disorder.
It measures, you know, which months do you feel the most tired, the most social, the most energetic? Do you change your eating habits? Do you change your sleeping habits? Do you change your socializing? Which months do you feel the best and worst? And the idea is that if you have really extreme seasonality, then you have winter depression. So if you say, oh, I sleep a lot more, I eat a lot more, I'm a lot less social in the winter, than you could be diagnosed with seasonal effective disorder.|||它衡量的是，你知道的，你在哪几个月感觉最疲惫、最合群、最有精力？你是否改变了饮食习惯？你是否改变了睡眠习惯？你是否改变了社交活动？你在哪几个月感觉最好和最差？其核心观点是，如果你有非常极端的季节性，那么你就有冬季抑郁症。所以如果你说：“哦，我在冬天睡得更多、吃得更多、社交少得多，”那么你就可以被诊断为患有季节性情感障碍。
And studies that use this criteria tend to find higher rates of seasonal effective disorder. But in my view, and I think in a lot of view of psychologists, even those who now study sad, this doesn't quite capture depression specifically, right? You could actually have pretty extreme seasonality and it could be really healthy and adaptive. And this is what I saw in Troso, right? people are changing their eating and sleeping and socializing habits, but it's not bothersome to them. They don't view it as a bad thing. They view it as living in tune with nature. And so now a lot of researchers prefer to use the more rigorous standard of first screening for clinical depression and then
And studies that use this criteria tend to find higher rates of seasonal effective disorder. But in my view, and I think in a lot of view of psychologists, even those who now study sad, this doesn't quite capture depression specifically, right? You could actually have pretty extreme seasonality and it could be really healthy and adaptive. And this is what I saw in Troso, right? people are changing their eating and sleeping and socializing habits, but it's not bothersome to them. They don't view it as a bad thing. They view it as living in tune with nature. And so now a lot of researchers prefer to use the more rigorous standard of first screening for clinical depression and then|||使用这一标准的研究所得出的季节性情感障碍发病率往往较高。但在我看来，我想在许多心理学家的眼中，甚至在那些现在研究SAD的人眼中，这并不能具体捕捉到抑郁症，对吧？你实际上可能具有相当极端的季节性，而且它可能非常健康且具有适应性。这也是我在特罗姆瑟看到的情况，对吧？人们在改变他们的饮食、睡眠和社交习惯，但这并没有困扰他们。他们不认为这是一件坏事。他们将其视为顺应自然的生活方式。因此，现在许多研究人员更倾向于使用更严格的标准，即首先筛查临床抑郁症，然后
looking for the seasonal pattern. And if you do that, we actually find much lower rates of seasonal effective disorder. And there's a lot of evidence that outside of the U.S. in places with very long harsh winters, so in Trumso, in the Netherlands, in Iceland, they find very low rates of seasonal effective disorder or no evidence of this seasonal pattern of depression. So a lot of people have sort of been questioning this idea of seasonal effective disorder. Is it useful? Do we want to look for you know, how common is it really? So it's really hard to give an exact prevalence. I would say, if you feel that you have clinical depression and you do feel that you have this seasonal pattern, that it's a good opportunity to seek treatment for depression as you would at any other time
looking for the seasonal pattern. And if you do that, we actually find much lower rates of seasonal effective disorder. And there's a lot of evidence that outside of the U.S. in places with very long harsh winters, so in Trumso, in the Netherlands, in Iceland, they find very low rates of seasonal effective disorder or no evidence of this seasonal pattern of depression. So a lot of people have sort of been questioning this idea of seasonal effective disorder. Is it useful? Do we want to look for you know, how common is it really? So it's really hard to give an exact prevalence. I would say, if you feel that you have clinical depression and you do feel that you have this seasonal pattern, that it's a good opportunity to seek treatment for depression as you would at any other time|||寻找季节性模式。如果你这样做，我们实际上会发现季节性情感障碍的发病率要低得多。有大量证据表明，在美国以外拥有漫长严冬的地方，比如在特罗姆瑟、荷兰、冰岛，他们发现季节性情感障碍的发病率非常低，或者没有这种季节性抑郁模式的证据。因此，许多人一直在质疑季节性情感障碍这个概念。它有用吗？我们想去寻找，你知道的，它到底有多普遍？所以很难给出一个确切的患病率。我想说的是，如果你觉得你患有临床抑郁症，并且你确实觉得你有这种季节性模式，那么这是一个寻求抑郁症治疗的好机会，就像你在一年中任何其他时间一样
of year. For most people, however, I think what's really important to acknowledge is that we are affected by winter and people are feeling that, right? You're feeling the impact of winter. You're on your energy, on your mood, on your appetite, on how much you sleep. And the problem, I think, comes with pathologizing that, with saying that's bad, right? I have friends who know what I study, who, you know, the second or third week of November after the clock's change, will be like, oh, I've been so tired. I just don't know what's wrong with me. And I'm like, hello, like, the days are shortening. You know, we've lost an hour in the evenings. Like, it's normal. to be more tired. And if you look at every other living thing on earth, plant or animal,
of year. For most people, however, I think what's really important to acknowledge is that we are affected by winter and people are feeling that, right? You're feeling the impact of winter. You're on your energy, on your mood, on your appetite, on how much you sleep. And the problem, I think, comes with pathologizing that, with saying that's bad, right? I have friends who know what I study, who, you know, the second or third week of November after the clock's change, will be like, oh, I've been so tired. I just don't know what's wrong with me. And I'm like, hello, like, the days are shortening. You know, we've lost an hour in the evenings. Like, it's normal. to be more tired. And if you look at every other living thing on earth, plant or animal,|||对于大多数人来说，我认为真正重要的是要承认我们受到了冬天的影响，人们确实感受到了这一点，对吧？你正在感受到冬天的影响。你的精力、你的情绪、你的食欲、你的睡眠时间都在受到影响。而问题在于，我认为，是将这种现象病理化，说这是不好的，对吧？我有一些知道我研究领域的朋友，你知道的，在11月的第二周或第三周时钟拨慢之后，会说：“哦，我好累啊。我真不知道自己怎么了。”而我会说：“喂，白天正在变短。你知道的，我们晚上的时间少了一个小时。觉得更累是正常的。”如果你看看地球上的其他所有生物，无论是植物还是动物，
they all change their behavior in winter. They almost all are resting more, sleeping more in the winter. And so I think, in my view, the best way to address the winter blues of this feeling that the season really does impact us is to say, okay, how can I work with these feelings? How can I say, yes, I am more tired in the winter? I sleep more in the winter. That's okay. Let me make space. for that, let me ease up on maybe my commitments or how much I socialize or what kind of activities I pursue and use winter as an opportunity to slow down rather than saying, oh, there's something wrong with me. I must be depressed if I'm more tired in the winter. We can say this is normal, this is healthy, this is adaptive. And this is one of these things that I actually think practicing
they all change their behavior in winter. They almost all are resting more, sleeping more in the winter. And so I think, in my view, the best way to address the winter blues of this feeling that the season really does impact us is to say, okay, how can I work with these feelings? How can I say, yes, I am more tired in the winter? I sleep more in the winter. That's okay. Let me make space. for that, let me ease up on maybe my commitments or how much I socialize or what kind of activities I pursue and use winter as an opportunity to slow down rather than saying, oh, there's something wrong with me. I must be depressed if I'm more tired in the winter. We can say this is normal, this is healthy, this is adaptive. And this is one of these things that I actually think practicing|||它们在冬天都会改变自己的行为。它们几乎都在冬天更多地休息、更多地睡眠。因此，在我看来，应对这种“冬季忧郁”——即感觉到这个季节确实对我们产生影响——的最佳方法是说：好吧，我如何与这些感受相处？我如何说：是的，我在冬天更累了？我在冬天睡得更多了？这没关系。让我为此留出空间，让我稍微放松一下我的承诺、我的社交频率或我追求的活动类型，把冬天当作一个放慢脚步的机会，而不是说：“哦，我一定有什么毛病。如果在冬天更累，我一定患了抑郁症。”我们可以说这是正常的、健康的、具适应性的。这也是其中一件事，我实际上认为进行
this in the winter is really powerful because we'll all have times when we're forced to slow down like it or not, right? You get sick. You have to have surgery. You're burnt out. You're grieving. You've given birth. Whatever it is, there's going to be times in our life where we're forced to sort of pump the brakes and rest more and prioritize restoration. And I think when we get in the habit of practicing that seasonally, maybe that can become a little bit easier for us when we have to do this at other times of life. Do you think that climate change is affecting how people feel? feel about winter and really how people emotionally react to it? I do. I do. I mean, you know, you can't write and talk and think about winter without writing and talking and thinking
this in the winter is really powerful because we'll all have times when we're forced to slow down like it or not, right? You get sick. You have to have surgery. You're burnt out. You're grieving. You've given birth. Whatever it is, there's going to be times in our life where we're forced to sort of pump the brakes and rest more and prioritize restoration. And I think when we get in the habit of practicing that seasonally, maybe that can become a little bit easier for us when we have to do this at other times of life. Do you think that climate change is affecting how people feel? feel about winter and really how people emotionally react to it? I do. I do. I mean, you know, you can't write and talk and think about winter without writing and talking and thinking|||这样的冬季练习非常有力，因为无论我们喜欢与否，我们都会遇到被迫慢下来的时候，对吧？你生病了。你必须做手术。你筋疲力尽。你在悲伤。你刚生了孩子。无论是什么，我们的生活中总会有这样的时候：我们被迫踩下刹车，多休息，并把恢复精力放在首位。我认为当我们养成按季节这样做的习惯时，也许当我们需要在生活的其他时刻这样做时，这会变得更容易一些。你认为气候变化正在影响人们对冬天的感觉以及人们对它的情感反应吗？我是这么认为的。我的意思是，你知道的，你不可能在不写作、谈论和思考的情况下，去书写、谈论和思考冬天。
about climate change, especially given my own personal ties to the Arctic. You know, I'm seeing people that I know living in Tromsa and even north of Trumsa and Svalbard, an island halfway between Northern Noray and the North Pole, who are experiencing very different winters because they're feeling the climate change in their season. You know, I started writing about this topic 10 years ago and then almost no one was asking me how to survive the heat and the summers. And now I'm getting more and more people saying, forget how to winter. How do I deal with these brutally hot summers? And also 10 years ago, no one was asking me what there is to lose when we lose winter. And now I'm getting a lot more questions about what do we lose when we lose?
关于气候变化，尤其是鉴于我自己与北极的个人联系。你知道的，我看到我认识的人住在特罗姆瑟，甚至在特罗姆瑟以北和斯瓦尔巴群岛（位于挪威北部和北极点正中间的一个岛屿），他们正在经历非常不同的冬天，因为他们在自己的季节里感受到了气候变化。你知道，我10年前开始写这个话题时，几乎没有人问我如何熬过酷暑和夏天。现在越来越多的人对我说，别管怎么过冬了，我该如何应对这些残酷的酷暑？而且10年前，也没有人问我，当我们失去冬天时，我们会失去什么。现在我有更多关于“当我们失去冬天时，我们究竟失去了什么”的疑问。
the season of winter. And I think there's a lot more people living in places, right, like the D.C. area, like Amsterdam, that are on the cusp where the difference of a few degrees in winter means the difference between snow in the winter, which reflects the light and opens up a whole host of activities that you can do in the winter and a long, rainy gray winter, like the one that we were talking about earlier. And so I think people are feeling more and more. that winter is in danger and that winter is precious. And I think we're also starting to see the ways that protecting winter protects other things that we love. So for example, in researching the book, I learned all about the process of vernalization, which is plants that need a certain number of
也就是冬天的季节。我认为有更多的人住在一些地方，比如华盛顿特区地区、阿姆斯特丹，这些地方正处于临界点，冬天温度相差几度，就意味着冬天是否有雪（雪能反射光线并开启一系列你可以在冬天进行的活动），还是像我们之前谈到的那样，是一个漫长、阴雨绵绵、灰暗的冬天。因此，我认为人们越来越强烈地感觉到，冬天正处于危险之中，冬天是珍贵的。而且我认为我们也开始看到，保护冬天也就是在保护我们热爱的其他事物。例如，在研究这本书的过程中，我了解到了春化作用的全过程，即植物需要一定数量的
chill hours in order to bloom successfully in the spring. So a lot of nuts and fruits, things like Peaches require a certain number of cold hours in order to bloom successfully. And when winter ends too early, that whole process is in danger. So I believe it was the 2022, 2022, 2023 season. It was very warm in Georgia and the southern U.S. The peaches started developing early. And then there was a freeze at a normal time, but the peaches had already developed. And so the peaches froze and they were all destroyed, and it destroyed the peach crop. And actually, that whole area of Georgia was declared a natural disaster zone because it had such a big impact on the crop. And so even things that we think of as enjoying in summer, like our favorite stone fruits, right, rely on winter to exist.
冷积温（冷凉小时数）才能在春天成功开花。因此，许多坚果和水果，比如桃子，需要一定数量的低温小时数才能成功开花。当冬天结束得太早时，整个过程就会面临危险。所以我想那是2022年，2022-2023年那个季节，佐治亚州和美国南部非常暖和，桃子开始提前发育。然后在一个正常的时间发生了霜冻，但桃子已经发育好了。结果桃子被冻坏了，全都毁了，这场霜冻摧毁了当年的桃子收成。事实上，佐治亚州的整个地区都被宣布为自然灾害区，因为它对农作物造成了如此巨大的影响。因此，甚至连我们认为在夏天才能享受的东西，比如我们最喜欢的核果，其实也依赖于冬天的存在。
And there's all of these kinds of interdependent things where when we don't have the proper freeze cycles, when we don't have the proper cold in the winter, it puts a lot of things. things in danger. And I think more and more people are starting to notice that. And I think the people who love winter are the most motivated to protect it. So I'm a member of the Science Alliance for an organization called Protect Our Winters, which was founded by Jeremy Jones, who is a pro snowboarder, as he started noticing that more and more, there weren't as many places for him to go snowboarding, or the snowboarding season was much shorter. And all around the country and all around the country and the world, there's people who love winter recreation, who love winter sports, who are really
所有这些相互依存的事情都是这样，当我们没有适当的冰冻周期，当我们在冬天没有适当的寒冷时，它会把很多事情置于危险之中。我认为越来越多的人开始注意到这一点。而且我认为热爱冬天的人是最有动力去保护它的人。所以我是“保护我们的冬天”（Protect Our Winters）组织科学联盟的成员，该组织由职业单板滑雪运动员杰里米·琼斯（Jeremy Jones）创立，因为他开始注意到，越来越多的时候，他找不到那么多地方去滑雪了，或者滑雪季节变得短得多了。在全国各地以及世界各地，有许多热爱冬季休闲、热爱冬季运动的人，他们真的
motivated to protect the season. And so I think this idea of appreciating winter, I hope, can help inspire more people to want to take action on climate change, to protect the winter, to protect the seasons, to protect the things that winter provides us so that we can have all of these opportunities, you know, for decades to come. When you were writing this book, you traveled to many cold weather places around the world to learn more about how other people do winter. Did you discover any other favorite winter traditions in addition to what the Norwegians do? Who else does winter really well? There's so many.
很有动力去保护这个季节。因此，我认为这种欣赏冬天的理念，我希望能够激励更多的人采取行动应对气候变化，保护冬天、保护各个季节、保护冬天赋予我们的一切，这样我们在未来几十年里都能拥有所有这些机会。你在写这本书时，去世界各地许多寒冷的地方旅行，以了解其他人是如何过冬的。除了挪威人的做法，你还发现了其他哪些最喜欢的冬季传统？还有谁把冬天过得很好？有很多。
I mean, one of the things I learned traveling around doing research for this book is that every culture, I think, has ways of celebrating and appreciating winter. if only you look for them. So for example, I went to the Outer Hebrides off the coast of Scotland because they have a really long, dark, wet, windy winter, but they don't get snow. And so I really wanted to say, okay, what do people do in a climate like that? And they do a lot of community gatherings. So the Gaelic word is called Kaley.
我的意思是，在为这本书做研究而四处旅行的过程中，我学到的一件事是，我认为每一种文化都有庆祝和欣赏冬天的独特方式，只要你去寻找它们。例如，我去了苏格兰海岸外的外赫布里底群岛，因为那里有非常漫长、黑暗、潮湿、风很大的冬天，但他们不下雪。所以我真的很想说，好吧，人们在这样的气候下会做什么？他们会进行大量的社区聚会。所以盖尔语的词汇叫做凯利（Kaley）。
It's Kaley culture. And this idea of coming together for communal events, dinners, celebrations gathering around telling stories sitting by the fire usually drinking whiskey you know is really essential for surviving these long dark nights um i was also really interested in cultures and how they seek warmth in the winter right so in finland sauna is you know a very sacred part of the culture you know in iceland where they have geothermal energy they go they have geothermal pools all over the country in Japan. Likewise, they also have geothermal baths and they do a lot of hot water bathing. And one thing that I found really interesting that I didn't know before I started
这就是凯利文化。人们聚在一起举办社区活动、晚宴、庆祝活动，围坐在一起讲故事、坐在火炉旁、通常还要喝威士忌，你知道的，这对于熬过漫长黑暗的夜晚至关重要。嗯，我也对各种文化以及它们在冬天如何寻求温暖很感兴趣，比如在芬兰，桑拿浴是文化中非常神圣的一部分；在冰岛，由于拥有地热能，他们会在全国各地建造地热温泉；在日本也是如此，他们也有地热浴，并且经常进行热水浴。我发现了一件非常有趣的事，在开始研究之前我并不知道
researching the book was that a lot of these things that people have been doing for thousands of years, right, like going to the onset in Japan, or going to the sauna in Finland, there's a whole host of recent research showing the health benefits of these activities and showing that they're protective against things like heart attack and Alzheimer's disease and they can treat arthritis and migraines and skin conditions. I mean, in Finland they've called the son of the poor man's pharmacy and the research is really corroborating that. And so this idea that activities we can enjoy in the winter that feel really special in the winter and that also feel good physically and emotionally are also very health promoting, I think is really powerful. I think, you know,
这本书的时候我了解到，人们几千年来一直在做许多事情，比如去日本的温泉，或者去芬兰洗桑拿，最近有大量研究表明这些活动对健康有益，并表明它们可以预防心脏病和阿尔茨海默病等疾病，还可以治疗关节炎、偏头痛和皮肤病。我的意思是，在芬兰，他们把桑拿称为“穷人的药房”，而研究确实证实了这一点。因此，这种我们可以在冬天享受的、在冬天感觉非常特别的、并且在身体和情感上都感觉良好的活动，同时也非常促进健康，我认为这是非常有力量的。我认为，你知道的，
sometimes we have this view of like if it's, if it doesn't hurt, it's not healthy. You know, if it's not, if it's not punishment, it's not health promoting. But I think in winter, there's a lot of ways to sink physical pleasure and health, whether that's just taking a hot bath or going to the sauna or, you know, slowing down and drinking a cup of tea. I think there's a lot of evidence growing that these things are really good for us and our life extending, even as they can feel sort of life-giving on these dark days of the season. So just to wrap up, are you still doing research in this area? What else are you working on now? So I am still doing research in one sense of the word. You know, I'm not doing a lot of academic research on this currently. But as I write and
有时我们会有这样一种观点：如果不痛，就不健康。你知道的，如果它不是一种惩罚，就不能促进健康。但我认为在冬天，有很多方法可以将身体的愉悦与健康结合起来，无论是洗个热水澡、蒸个桑拿，还是放慢脚步喝一杯茶。越来越多的证据表明，这些东西对我们真的很有好处，而且能够延年益寿，即使它们在一年中黑暗的日子里能让我们感受到生命的活力。所以总结一下，你现在还在这个领域做研究吗？你现在还在忙些什么？所以从某种意义上说，我仍在做研究。你知道，我目前没有在这个领域做太多的学术研究。但是当我写作时
talk and speak about this, there's so much to learn from other cultures and a lot to explore and I would love to sort of come back to this idea of researching winter mindset and winter well-being. I'm mostly focused on psychology communication right now, so this kind of writing and speaking and teaching, but I have some ongoing collaborations with some of my former lab members from the Stanford Mind and Body Lab. There's some very exciting work coming out of King's College in London, a colleague of mine, Lauren Heathcote, who is working on helping survivors of childhood cancer to adopt more useful mindsets about their bodies and their health and how can we help these kids monitor their bodies and monitor their health symptoms in ways that are less
谈论和宣讲这个话题，从其他文化中可以学到很多东西，也有很多值得探索的地方，我非常希望能回到研究“冬季思维模式”和“冬季福祉”这个理念上来。我目前主要专注于心理学传播，所以主要是这种写作、演讲和教学工作，但我与斯坦福身心实验室（Stanford Mind and Body Lab）的一些前实验室成员有一些正在进行的合作。伦敦国王学院（King's College）也正在开展一些非常令人兴奋的工作，我的同事劳伦·希思科特（Lauren Heathcote）正致力于帮助儿童癌症幸存者对自己的身体和健康采取更有用的思维模式，以及我们如何帮助这些孩子们以一种不太
threatening and less anxiety inducing. And so I think, I hope that winter mindset will be an entryway for your listeners to start diving into all of the ways that mindset can influence our health and well-being. And there's a lot of really exciting research happening in this area now. I think we're just at the very beginning of understanding the impact of mindset, the mechanisms of mindset, and really the potential of mindset to improve our lives in many different ways. Well, Dr. Leibowitz, want to thank you for joining me today. This has been great. This was so wonderful. Thanks for your thoughtful questions. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org
具有威胁性、较少引发焦虑的方式来监测自己的身体和健康症状。因此，我希望冬季思维模式能成为你听众的一个入口，让他们开始深入了解思维模式能够影响我们健康和福祉的各种方式。目前这一领域正在进行许多非常激动人心的研究。我认为我们才刚刚开始了解思维模式的影响、思维模式的机制，以及思维模式在许多不同方面改善我们生活的潜力。好吧，莱博维茨博士，非常感谢您今天能来到节目中。这太棒了。这太美妙了。谢谢你深思熟虑的问题。你可以在我们的网站 speakingof psychology.org 上找到往期的《心理学访谈》节目
or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get. your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. You can't reason with the sun. Trust us. We've tried. This summer, it's time to put that angry ball of fire on mute. Columbia's Omnishade Technology is engineered to protect you from the sun's harsh rays that can burn and damage your skin. The sun is relentless, but so is our gear.
或者在苹果、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。《心理学访谈》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢收听，我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。你无法跟太阳讲道理。相信我们，我们试过了。今年夏天，是时候把那个愤怒的火球按静音了。哥伦比亚（Columbia）的 Omnishade 技术旨在保护您免受阳光强烈射线的伤害，这些射线会灼伤和损害您的皮肤。太阳是冷酷无情的，但我们的装备也是。
Level up your summer at Columbia.com to spend more time outside and less time slathering on alo lotion. You're welcome. Columbia. Engineered for whatever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 Columbia.com 升级你的夏天，花更多时间在户外，少花时间涂抹芦荟乳液。不用谢。Columbia。为各种可能而生。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。